[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight Jeffrey Epstein died
some weeks ago months ago at this point
but basic questions remain unanswered
among them what a powerful people appear
to be covering up for him still there's
a new development in the Jeffrey Epstein
story tonight we're gonna bring you in
just a minute we're sticking around for
but first tonight former New York City
Mayor Michael Bloomberg appears to be
running for president now in the plus
column
Bloomberg is one of the richest people
in America more than 10 million dollars
more money that he could ever spend
he's also highly popular on the set of
the MSNBC Morning Show and he's
absolutely beloved on Martha's Vineyard
during the summer months
again that's the upside to the candidacy
on the other hand Bloomberg is not
exactly the man that Democratic primary
voters picture when they dream about
their ideal candidate maybe that's why
prominent Democrats reacted to the news
today this way
well John do you think the country
really wants another New York
billionaire after Donald Trump usually
we elect the opposite we very often
underestimate the level of affection
there is among Democratic voters for Joe
Biden Mike Bloomberg whatever his you
know whatever good things you can say
about him he just doesn't have this
feels a little bit like a Hail Mary for
a certain class of folks I think it
would be more genuine if he would
actually run as a Republican
given his record and don't see any room
here he's a relatively ideologically
neutral billionaire and there are zero
people clamoring for that right now
and David Mike Bloomberg is also another
white subcision Aryan who is entering
the race as well many asking if that's
something that we need at this point oh
he's a white man says to CNN anchor
maybe we're asking if we need that right
now
well you can mock and dismiss that but
for a party increasingly controlled like
racial comma stars like the one you just
saw Brianna gold Rega Bloomberg is a
pretty tough sell the Democratic base is
not exactly clamoring for their own
elderly
their candidate as you just heard and
that's true but here's the problem on
the other hand Wall Street liberals and
their many of those are not happy about
Elizabeth Warren either and that when
you take three steps back is the real
story here you're not watching a United
confident political party this is what
it looks like when a party declares war
on itself the core problem is there is a
massive gap between the components of
the Democratic coalition between
Nantucket and the Bronx between
unionized auto workers in Ohio and
non-binary trans activists of color in
San Francisco it turns out the
Democratic Coalition has essentially
nothing in common so for the first three
years the Trump administration that
hasn't been a problem everyone's been so
focused on hating Trump orange man bad
but suddenly they have to pick a
contender their own nominee and suddenly
this is a real problem some of us are
enjoying it by the way